in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us people across the country are
coming together to protect the families
of health care workers from exposure to
the corona virus
Mireya Villarreal shows us how one act
of kindness led to a nationwide movement
called RVs for n DS it is real it's
people are dying when you're fighting on
the frontlines rest is often the last
thing on your mind very very sick unique
Douglas mattis is a nurse practitioner
working with coronavirus patients in an
Atlanta ICU with a husband and three
young children at home two considered
high-risk she wrestled with a very
powerful fear when I went to work and I
saw the gravity I called my husband I
say I don't think I can come home the
babies I think I could get them sick
that's when a friend told her about this
Facebook page RVs for MDS a group that
connects people in the medical
profession needing to quarantine with
someone who has a camper nearby for free
[Music]
I can't touch and kiss them and you know
smell my babies Here I am okay and I'm
just just grateful I'm really filled
with Emily Phillips a mother of three
was the first to post a plea for help
when you posted this online did you
think anybody was gonna respond no I
just thought maybe somebody might have a
an RV or camper so we just were throwing
things out there and I got an immediate
response Emily's husband Jason Phillips
is an ER doctor in North Texas as I have
a high chance of getting exposed and I
think my wife came up with the best
solution I really didn't wanna stay in a
hotel full time and be separated from
them Emily turned her experience into a
movement
are now more than 22,000 people in the
RV's 4m DS group so far at least 345
matches have been made with hundreds
pending Emily runs the group with more
than a hundred volunteers including
Holly Haggard the first person to offer
up her RV to the Philips family it
doesn't matter who you vote for it
doesn't matter what your religious
beliefs aren't none of that matters
everybody has just come together they're
successful matches from Virginia
California and North Carolina I read
about the first emergency position that
has passed and it my stomach's think and
I'm like we need this now Dean accretion
turned to the group to find an RV for
her husband John and ER physician Tanya
sheets drove three hours to deliver her
camper we knew we had to jump in to do
something John expects to quarantine
soon and how long could this last we
don't know until we know that he is safe
and ok for us to go back to normal
look at this Wow the road to normalcy
may be longer than most would like but
the journey just got a little bit
smoother whether it's kindness that
connects this or love that connects this
all right mama love you we will come out
of this entire situation much better for
CBS this morning media via North Texas
Bravo I love that gal and you know
what's so wonderful about it is those
vehicles are mobile you can park them
any way and you can walk out and wave to
your family yes and you can see your
family all the time and they're
comfortable I think there's another
epidemic going on guys it's an epidemic
of compassion compassion kindness always
yes